logic programs that are a result
of a close collaboration between find
biotech and innovative big data
analytics company based in the us
and numerous academic institutions that
have participated in content evaluation
curriculum review and project design
as a result omits logic programs have
been thoroughly tested around the world
and are known to lead to excellent
outcomes for students with minimal
bioinformatics background
including biology and biomedical studies
majors as well as faculty
interested in bioinformatics data
science
and biomedical research omits logic
is an international program that is
running in five
different regions with over 10 000 users
around the world due to this fast growth
our team is working with local and
regional coordinators that are helping
to refine
the local program logistics and leverage
our online training resources
adapting them to the needs of students
and researchers around the world
the goal of the omits logic program is
to provide
training in bioinformatics enabling
independent research
guided by mentors and peer example
developing a growing community with
shared passion for data driven
research and appreciation of citizen
science
enabling students clinicians and faculty
of all backgrounds
to develop novel and independent
research using
latest technology in life and data
sciences
we will combine online sessions
self-guided study materials and
practical assignments
for an immersive experience that has
proven to be effective in our well-known
and respected omics logic programs
now let me introduce you to the
resources
so let us start by creating a free
account
on learn.omicslogic.com
so i am posting the link in the chat box
so that everybody is able to come with
me to learn.omicslogic.com
so if you are there um you need to click
on login
and you will find that there are several
options that you can get
which is you can either sign in via your
email
or you can also utilize any of these
social media login options
that you receive and for all
participants
attending today's session we have sent
you a detailed overview
of how to get started with each of the
platforms
you should have uh your also the login
to the t buyer info platform
and we have also sent you links to the
omits logic slack account
so this is a portal that we would be
using
to communicate with each other and many
of our participants here
are used to the forums that we have as
part of the edu platform
now as we are going to move to
learn.ormixlogic we will be utilizing
slack for that kind of communication
and i also want to invite everybody to
go ahead and check our linkedin channel
so let me take you all
uh to the platform and see
how it works so this is the learn
dot omits logic platform so how many of
you have been able to go to learn
and this is free for everyone so please
feel free to join
and work together with me so
how many of you are there on
learn.omicslogic.com
please put number one in the chat box
if you are there
great so rt is there anybody else
perfect so you would notice that there
is a login button
so i clicked on the login button that is
right here so everybody
should get that button so please click
on login
and once you come here you would notice
the sign-in page
so if you are already a user of any of
our platforms
and you have a particular message so
please feel free to use the same
email id that you have been using while
others can
also use any of these uh social media
sign in so i will sign into the account
so once i'm signed into the account
it takes me directly to the different
courses that we have
so we have a basic introductory courses
that we are still launching with bytes
and molecules
and as the focus for this session
is genomics we have this course called
genomics and it is divided into several
lessons
so i would really ask everyone to start
with
introduction to genomics uh after this
session so that you can learn about what
we are going to be covering
and also you can continue to explore all
of these different
lessons right here and if you go back
and explore the courses you will also
find that we have added lessons
in python and r as well so everything is
integrated into this one platform
and as you're going through this you
would also see that
once you create an account if you click
on your email id
right here you are able to see your
achievements and your activity
so everything that you do in the
platform would be tracked
now let me show you what we are going to
be doing with
slack so this is how the slack channel
looks like
all participants in the program have
received an
invitation via email to this channel so
as you see i have
posted about the first session and elia
has also added
about the session and added an image
here so you can actually
write here or ask us any questions
regarding this
so please feel free to explore the slack
platform and in case you have
any questions please feel free to ask us
there
and the second platform that we have
is the code uh is the linkedin platform
which i would again welcome everybody to
join
so this is the linkedin platform and
why we welcome you all to join this
platform is because
this gives you an opportunity to connect
with
people who are not only part of your
local community
but other bioinformaticians clinicians
as well as industry experts who belong
to our
community and join us from all over the
world so you can actually see the number
of
connections we have here and you can
extend these connections
which will be helpful for you as well
and we also have
this platform on facebook which again or
this facebook group that you can again
connect on so i hope that you are able
to explore all of these platforms
together
and sign up to learn dot omics logic for
everybody else who are still not part of
the omixlogic genomic program
or any of the other omics logic programs
there are several
free resources here on code on
i mean the learn platform that you can
explore
so please feel free to explore and we
are also listing here
the different campuses as well as
the community that we have all over the
world so you can also explore
this section here now let me quickly go
back to the presentation and introduce
you
to the mentors
of this session so we have dr harpreet
kaur she's our bioinformatics trainer
and she has a phd in bioinformatics she
will be
guiding the sessions dr mohit
is our project and partnerships mentor
and he also has a phd in computational
biology
ilia brodsky here is our co-founder and
ceo and now i would want to invite elia
to talk more about genomic data analysis
over to you elia
thank you thank you very much pipsa
and welcome everyone to this program i'm
excited to see you all here
and hope that you will have a pleasant
experience today with
what we've prepared so i hope that
by this time everyone already had a
chance to sign up
and create your account uh it is a big
transition for us
we just recently crossed over 10 000
users from around the world
and unfortunately that comes with
greater demand for computational
resources
which we knew was coming and so we have
been building out this site for quite
some time
we hope that the new features that we're
going to introduce are going to be
useful
and will resolve a lot of the issues
that a lot of the users have been
complaining about in the past
now to talk about this program i want to
start by
reviewing how the previous portion of
the program
called bioinformatics for infectious
disease research and training
really helped set the stage for what we
will be covering in this
part of the genomics training program so
in the first six
months of the program we spent
considerable time
looking at some introductory materials
that were covering sequence variation
and alignment where we looked at
multiple sequence alignment
pairwise sequence alignment and
different variations of these types of
methods
we looked at evolutionary and
phylogenetic analysis where we looked at
phylogenetic trees and we looked at the
relationships between
viral bacterial and fungal genomes by
analyzing alignments of full genomes or
individual genes we also looked at how
to interpret genomic variation by
looking at functionality and protein
structure
identifying specific regions that were
more
conserved or less conserved and how the
interaction between proteins can help us
interpret the functional properties of
these mutations
and we also touched on the
transcriptomic analysis of host response
and even though this program was
over one month long we had great
sessions where we got to describe
different project examples and see
practically how to analyze such data
this program was actually an
introduction
and so after we have completed this
first introduction
we hope that it provided a perspective
for the participants that
joined how they can maybe improve
their projects through incorporating
additional data types
by validating some of their findings
using other types of omnics data
and by doing some literature review on
how other research projects have
leveraged data sets from different
repositories
to combine them together and make their
projects more
impactful so the transition from this
introductory program to this more
in-depth program on genomics is really
focused
on a deeper dive into the genomic data
analysis
and so even though we talked about
multiple sequence alignment and we
talked about phylogenetic trees and we
talked about
interpreting the biological components
of those mutations
there are so many things that we did
just did not have time
to complete and so this is
phase two of this uh bioinformatics for
infectious disease program
it will be more focused on
in-depth analysis of genomic data and i
will explain
briefly what are some of the specifics
that we will touch on
in a few slides but we also want to
make sure that the projects that have
been started
and developed in the first part of the
program the project proposals
are going to be enhanced and
advanced through this kind of training
so a big
part of this program is not just the
training itself
but continuing to work on specific
project
examples together with our mentors and
our team
to develop further the projects
themselves as well as resources
tools and understanding around the
specific areas for example
in our last program we talked about
different data repositories
and reviewed a lot of literature that
has to do with the specific
topics of interest that are very uh
pressing and important in the domain of
malaria
and covid19 and we have been able to
work together with our collaborators at
the tower bioinformatics research center
to discuss with them how the specific
project ideas
could be enhanced with particular
methods of analysis
and particular ideas about the analysis
results that we hope will make these
projects more impactful
now for those of you that are joining us
for the first time
i think it's important to understand
that we have continuous training
like this throughout the year we do
these projects
uh together with our research fellows as
well as
researchers students and faculty that
come and join the research programs and
we are always interested
in helping more faculty researchers and
students
develop independent projects that
leverage bioinformatics
and online data repositories so to speak
a little bit
about the previous program and some of
the outcomes
i want to invite dr harpreet kaur to
share about her background and also
introduce
some of the things that she's observed
in the previous program
so dr karour i'll pass it on to you
thank you
just let me share my screen
so hello everyone my name is harpreet
kaur and i have a phd
in bioinformatics currently i am
bioinformatics trainer with the pine
biotic
where i am assisting participants to
learn various aspects
of data analysis machine learning and
we are also designing different research
projects
so in our previous program that is
bioinformatics for infectious diseases
we have covered different aspects for
regarding the
disease so like we have also learned
about
uh understanding of the various
pathogens and this is that caused by
them and here we also covered uh two of
the major projects that is one is covaid
19
and another one another one is ebola
then we also learned about
various analysis approach to understand
their origin and finding the difference
between different
haplotypes and then we have also learned
how we can design
our own research process so for that we
have
learned how we can curate data from the
public repository
and then we can ask a different
questions like
regarding their reason then we also
learned about what could be
the effect of those different types of
mutations
and then we also learned about what
could be
how you can find the relationship
between host
and the the host and the uh
pathogen so here we have also learned
about different
types of data like genome uh genomics
data
like fast faster files then we also look
at the transcriptomics data
to understand various aspects of these
infectious diseases
so here our participants have uh
played a different i have learned lot of
respects and they have actively party uh
they have actively shown to complete
different courses
and they have also practiced various
courses and as well as they
perform various types of analysis
so then we have uh one of the uh
they have based on their previous
learning so
and based on their background so they
have designed
a research question so like
uh curry's had designed his his
questions based on
uh his learning from this program
as well as his background knowledge
so like he's he he has designed his
research project entitled genetic
variation studies of sexuality
pacific antigen pfs 230
and pfs 48 45
of plasmodium falciparum population on
africa and their potential implication
on transmission blocking
vaccines apart from currents there are
various other participants which have
designed their research questions
based on their learning as well as uh
their background
so they have tried to address different
research questions
so we are looking forward how you can
actually
uh even in the upcoming program how you
are going to implement
and complete your research projects
based on the genomic data analysis
so i'm looking forward being your mentor
so most of these projects are actually
uh
uh uh have uh uh we have reviewed these
uh projects and we have asked few of the
set a few of the criteria based on first
criteria that we have
observed what kind of question that they
are going
to address then whether this question is
actually
noble enough for a public
and then whether the data set that they
are analyzing
that is good enough to uh to address
that
question and next our criteria
is to find out what are their analysis
approach
so whether they have the sufficient
knowledge
about the all the algorithm uh
which they are going to use to address
their question
so eventually we have fined four of the
five very good projects
uh depending upon about the criteria
so we are looking forward uh in our
upcoming program
that you will able to complete these
research projects and also
learn a new aspect like where you can
use a genomic data
to address your question so now i would
like
pass this session back to ilya so
over to you ilya thank you very much dr
harpreet
and hopefully this also helps us
understand
how this program is going to help you
further advance your project ideas
and continue your research
so but before we jump into how this
program is going to be structured and
what are the different topics that we
will cover
i want to pose a question that might be
relevant to all of us
interested and maybe involved in
research related to infectious diseases
so in 2017 what has been
shown through different statistics
gathered from around the world is that
communicable
maternal neonatal and nutritional
diseases
all kind of bundled together but they in
include infectious diseases have been
steadily
on the decline and you can see that the
primary focus was actually on
non-communicable diseases such as cancer
diabetes and others
and what's interesting about that is
that the health systems around the world
including a lot of research funding has
actually been diverted from infectious
diseases
to the challenges associated with these
other types of diseases like
chronic diseases like cancer
and others and what has changed
obviously in the past year
is that all of a sudden we see this
major rise in mortality and prevalence
of an infectious disease that shows how
these various comorbidities including
heart disease
cancer and other types of
respiratory diseases for example are all
major factors to consider but
also in the context of infectious
diseases
and so this i think is an opportunity
for all of us to think
again about the centrality of infectious
diseases the importance moving forward
i think we will all see major changes in
funding mechanisms specifically designed
to address
emerging infectious diseases around the
world
including in africa and asia
we will see a major focus on genomic
data
and ngs data in general that has become
so central to this covet 19 outbreak
and we will see how this will provide an
important opportunity
for those neglected tropical diseases
as we see their centrality to how
susceptible
different populations there are to code
19 and other infections
and how they change our understanding at
the basic
biological level of what are the
mechanisms and processes
that we should consider for prevention
treatment
and intervention for different types of
emerging infectious diseases
and so in fact if we look over the
history
i think what's very interesting is that
these outbreaks
endemic and pandemic outbreaks around
the world
of infectious diseases have caused these
major loss in life
throughout the centuries and in the past
century alone
we see in the past maybe 50 years
or less we see these
major outbreaks happening again and
again so you can see here just in the
last part of the slide
right here starting with maybe spanish
flu
in 1918 we see then asian flu
hong kong flu then we see hiv
we see sars swine flu mers
ebola and finally coca-19
so obviously these numbers here are a
little bit outdated
but it really shows how in the last
century
there has been an acceleration of
infectious disease outbreaks caused by
pathogens
that might be even not considered alive
right because viruses
in many cases cannot be categorized
exactly as
living and so to learn about the
different measures
of intervention and the way that these
diseases have been addressed and
prevented and
treated in the past we can look at the
history of different measures that were
developed for example
how specific measures on the public
health side
such as first continuous
municipal use of chlorine in water in
the united states
or how we can see specific
novel treatments like penicillin
and how we see specific vaccines being
designed over time
how these interventions that were
really brought forth by the scientific
community
have helped us establish a an approach
to diagnose identify specifically
the cause of a disease to understand the
basic the basic
mechanisms of disease and then to
look in nature for existing
interventions and responses that could
be enhanced or
repurposed for a particular challenge
have been used
uh in the past hundred 100 years
to really limit the number of deaths as
you can see
right here the rate of mortality from
infectious diseases
and so to look at these specifically in
detail
we're going to continue looking at
several examples
that include ebola
different types of infectious diseases
that
emerge as a result of biotechnological
advances
how we can look at data coming from the
novel coronavirus and associated
coronaviruses
we will also take a look at bacterial
infections like tuberculosis
where we see an emergence of multi-drug
resistant strains of tuberculosis
so we will actually take a look at a lot
of the applications of genomic data
analysis
in the context of these projects that
were sourced
from publications that play a major role
in
infectious disease research around the
world so here are some examples of
projects that we already started talking
about and we will continue to review
using additional methods of analysis and
learning about how
data analysis approaches can help us
explore understand
ask specific research questions and make
sound conclusions that could be
presented
in the context of a research challenge
that we're trying to address
so one of them that we've kind of
started developing in the context of
this first part of the program
is how does bioinformatics analysis play
a major role
in understanding of malaria the
diversity of the pathogen
the interaction between vectors
pathogens
and the hosts and how we can use that
understanding
to really evaluate the efficacy of
vaccines that are appropriate at
different stages of
infection how we can measure the
interaction between different proteins
and understand how maybe that
interaction could be intervened in
as well as to understand the different
vaccines that are designed to prevent
transmission to also prevent infection
and what can be done in the context of
the low rates of efficacy of vaccines
that have been seen up until now
we will also speak about the emergence
of selective pressure outcomes as a
result of the introduction of
novel vaccines and antiviral treatments
for
sars cove too so we already know that
the vaccines are being rolled out around
the world
we know that there are asymptomatic
patients and patients
with a suppressed immune system we also
know about the variability of infection
around the world
and some of the questions that we're
going to continue to ask is how
do these selective pressures change
the virus itself and the population
dynamic
that we are so familiar with seeing as
the pandemic continues
so we'll try to think about what is the
future
of how these different clades that have
emerged over time and
in fact have diversified this pandemic
from just the single strand to multiple
strains of the virus
and how the interaction with the host
immune response
the different treatments and
interventions that are trying to that
are being introduced
will change the course of this pandemic
and how we will start looking at
zoonotic transmission over the next
decade
to address these emerging pathogens
one of these pathogens that i of course
mentioned ebola
has seen a continuous series of
outbreaks throughout the past several a
couple of decades
that it really shows that one of the
pressing challenges
is the changing ecological context of
this disease
so in fact the prevalence of ebola in a
particular region
and the interaction between different
animal uh
hosts that have been contained up until
now and maybe not
as exposed to interaction with humans as
well as the changing
climate might give us some sense of
what are the factors to consider as
these pandemics
are bound to happen once again and we'll
also take a look at a very fascinating
history
of the vaccine design and antiviral drug
design for these novel vaccine for these
novel pathogens
that have been produced in a record time
so we see
this with covet but a big part of what
we see with covet
is actually the result of what started
happening with ebola
that happened just recently in 2014
2016.
so we're talking about less than 10
years ago where ebola
outbreak was actually one of the major
events
that put that gave a central role
to next generation sequencing and
genomic data analysis
and in fact we see how genomic data that
is
cheaper to produce easier to analyze and
people are becoming better and better at
making sound predictions
about the importance of the different
changes will actually accelerate the
field
of bioinformatics in application to
genomic data
specifically in the context of vaccine
design
drug design and prevention and so
another important area that i already
mentioned is the emergence of multi-drug
resistance with
tuberculosis and multi drug resistant
tuberculosis
is actually prevalent in very specific
regions that include
russia asia like china pakistan india
bangladesh south africa nigeria and
other african countries
as well as in south america and so
what's interesting is that
we have a lot of information about the
way that this tuberculosis
these tuberculosis strains have been
treated and so understanding the basic
mechanisms
of resistance as well as the interaction
with those drugs
can help us study genomic data and find
important associations between genomic
variation
and what we know about drug
susceptibility and resistance of
mycobacterium tuberculosis
so we will actually take a look at
specific types of antibiotic
function how they interact with the
different strains
the emerging mutations in those strains
will take
real data sets and analyze them and then
perform
genome-wide association studies to find
associated variants
with that drug resistance and we'll also
think about how similar approaches could
be applied
to source code too could be applied to
malaria
could be applied to other diseases as
well
so to kind of summarize what we will do
in this program is we will spend another
month
learning about different approaches to
bioinformatics
these approaches are going to be used by
the participants to
enhance or develop further their
bioinformatics research studies
and work with our mentors to really see
how these projects could be
maybe in collaboration with others or
maybe independently
could be completed at the next phase to
maybe
make those projects again into
presentations to our
peer community to get some feedback and
expert advice
and potentially complete some of the
exploratory
and comparative analysis that we will do
using
some of the tools that we will learn
about so what are these tools
that we're going to be using well as you
probably can imagine
there has been a significant growth in
the number
of data sets that are available for
anyone to be able to analyze so what you
can see
here are a number of different types of
sequencing technologies
aluminum icy kaisek and others
including sequencing with oxford
manipore
and with pac-pacific biosciences pac-bio
and so we see both an increase
in the number of data sets that are
available but also in the types of data
sets that are available
targeted sequencing whole genome
sequencing
amplicon sequencing and many others and
so what we're trying to do is we will
introduce you
to additional methods of analysis on our
big data
t-bioinfo platform where you will be
able to analyze
hundreds of samples with large
quantities of data
performing in-depth and complex analysis
with a focus on integration because
ultimately
what this platform provides is an
ability to
process analyze visualize
and integrate multiple types of omics
data
so what are the types of data that we're
going to be speaking about
first of all we will continue to speak
about sequence alignment
both in the context of faster files
and fast queue reads because there's a
lot that could be done
as we start to understand the
differences between different methods
and the specific outputs that are
important for the different methods of
analysis
one of the things that we will look at
are the specific types
of analyses that allow us to understand
relationships between sequences
and study the structure of identified
relationships in the context of a
population
or in the context of a comparison
between multiple types of phylogenetic
relationships
so we'll try to take different types of
phylogenetic trees
and analyze them for how well they
represent
what we observe in data how do they
explain the relationships between
different strains
that are related or not related how they
could be applied to different
geolocation studies so that we can
analyze populations and associate them
with
phenotype we'll also take a look at a
detailed analysis
of raw fast q data sets that contain
millions of reads and show a lot of
variation that is lost when we just look
at consensus sequences
so we'll take a look at such important
information
as mutability or how frequently we
observe different mutations
in different types of populations we
look at
coverage between different regions and
how this important metric can help us
make
comparisons and understand our data
in the context of the limitations of
sequencing
and the opportunities for high coverage
consistent quality regions
that we observe in our data we'll also
look
at the application of such information
to the study
of interaction with the immune system
and how we can use conservation
epistasis
mutability and other types of factors to
categorize different regions
and their susceptibility to genomic
variation
some important tools that we will
discuss are the analysis of mutations
visually so that we could
explore specific regions that we have
understood
how to compare different regions of
mutations between groups of samples or
individual samples like in germline
somatic mutations in cancer
or like mutability and variation from
the reference genome
and the specific haplotypes that we
observe in infectious diseases
we will also look at other types of
method of genomic analysis
that will allow us to ask specific
questions
for the host response and also for the
interaction between the pathogen and the
host
and also we will look at how diversity
of some populations of viruses bacteria
and pathogens
can help us interpret fast q files that
have been produced as a
reason as a result of sequencing pooled
data that is often happening when we
take samples from individual
patients or pull data from multiple
patients and they're not not
demultiplex also talk about
genome-wide association studies that are
important for us to understand
the impact of multiple mutations spurred
across
different regions of the genome as they
work together to produce
a an observed interaction with treatment
or with other types of important
phenotypes now what's important about
this data
as corporate has already mentioned is
that a lot of this data
has been made available and what's
important to understand is how to
properly
navigate different resources understand
the specific types of data sets that are
available
look at the quality and the metadata
and organize our data to structure it in
such a way that we can answer
specific research questions and so we
have already
looked at a variety of malaria
repositories like malaria gen
and plasmodb we've looked at ncbi
virus where we can find information
about viral strains
and genomic variants associated with
specific types of pathogens
we will also look at different
repositories for bacterial infections
and so
what we will try to do is schedule a way
to prepare our data set
organize it and describe the metadata
and to be able to think about
what types of outputs from analysis are
expected
so that we know whether we can answer a
specific
research question we will also spend
some considerable time
working with protein structures and
there we will see
both the specific kinds of properties
like hydrophobic or polarity or
electrostatic
and think about the interaction between
different
portions of proteins complexes and
proteins to other proteins
as well as do docking and interaction
with
specific ligands where we can study the
specific mutations and changes in amino
acid
properties and the interaction with
molecules
and other proteins we will also look at
the response
from the specific treatments and
think about drug repurposing so that we
can analyze data
that can have an important component of
genomic data analysis
as we try to interpret how the drug
response
and the treatment response and outcomes
could be mapped to genomic and
transcriptomic data
so to summarize we will look at viral
genomics and evolution we revisit
phylogenetic trees multiple sequence
alignment and an analysis of raw fast q
reads
we will look at the epitopes so that we
can understand
immune responses and how genomic data
can provide us with insights
about the interaction with the immune
system we will think about the community
of viruses and how
they work together so that they can
use the diversity of that population to
overcome immune responses
and we will also think about pathway
analysis to measure
and interpret biological significance of
found variance
and the interaction between proteins
that we have
identified so let me now share a little
bit about
the schedule of this program again
the program is called genomic data
analysis with a focus on infectious
diseases
beeps if you could share once again the
link to the registration page
so for those of you that are joining for
the first time
today we have this link called
genomics.omixlogic.com
there you will see the schedule and i
will
go through the schedule to explain what
are the specific sessions
and what will be covered in those
sessions but before i do
i want to ask whether you have
any questions about what i have asked so
far
or what i have spoken about so far so
are there any questions
before we move on
okay thank you muhammad
okay so uh if no one has any other
questions
i have my first question to you so um
for those of you that are
um in today's session how many of you
actually have already created an account
on learn.oxlogic.com
if you have please put number one
and okay thank you are you ready again
for those of you that have
joined from a previous program your same
account information from codemix logic
should be available
should work okay excellent thank you
okay and and i want to also ask um okay
so
my second question is and instead of
putting number one in the chat box if
you're gonna put number two in the chat
box if you
confirm or no if if you
haven't right so if you have uh
already started working on a research
project
please put number two okay so if you
have started working
on your research project
okay and if you have not
put no
okay thank you courage okay
brenda okay
okay excellent so for those of you that
have
not yet started on a research project
this is going to be the opportunity to
learn
from your peers that have already
started their research project
so courage abukari zakaria
mohammed so some of you are already
working on some research projects
for you this is our opportunity to meet
new people that might be able to
contribute to your project enhance it
and maybe introduce new questions that
might be important to ask
for those of you that have not started a
project this is an
opportunity to learn from those that
have spent the past month or so
developing a research project and
identifying a data set
refining that research question and
proposing a specific project that
has uh specific competitive uh
characteristics that will
continue in this session okay
so um being said whenever you're ready
with the poll
let me know and then in the meantime
i'll go through
the schedule okay so first of all we
will start reviewing
some important information about
mutations in general
but also how they play a specific role
in
infectious diseases and so in infectious
diseases as you might imagine
they play a role in two ways the first
one
is genomic variation of the host and the
genomic variation of the host
is an important part of our
understanding about variation in
population response to disease
so for example we know where there's a
prevalence of malaria infection
sickle cell disease or in different
types of populations with diabetes
and their change in weight and other
types of
kind of predisposition or comorbidities
can have a very important response
difference in response to infection
so we will take a look at genomic
variation kind of clarify the
terminology make sure that this
terminology is clear from
project examples where we will see how
this terminology
will help us understand and study
important questions
so then today we will actually
introduce the different resources and
hopefully most of you that are joining
the program have already completed your
registration
but we will cover how the specific
elements
of the program fit together to advance
your research project
and so we'll talk about the project
examples that have been prepared as case
studies for you to learn from
we'll talk about pipelines and today at
the end of this session we'll take a
look at one of these pipelines that we
want to run
we'll look at the coding component where
you can learn
to run and analyze a
data set and visualize it or maybe look
at a statistical test in
r or python and we'll take a look at how
the sessions that we will cover in the
next couple of minutes
will lead to a greater appreciation for
what the genomic data can provide
in the context of your research question
so one important thing that we'll focus
on
is how the emerging centrality
of next generation sequencing is
actually changing
infectious disease in general and
medicine
and clinical applications of uh analysis
of genomic data so
like most of you know a big part of
working with such data
is being able to code and
automate some of your analysis and so to
illustrate this
and for those of you that are already
familiar with this
i want to show you one of the courses
that
we will use as an example to look at
genomic variation so to do that
let's go to on learn
comicslogic.com so please let me know
once you're
logged in i'm just going to log in here
real quick
okay so as i mentioned you can use uh
different types of
accounts here you don't have to create
an account or you can register
so let's go in i will use my google
account to register and
log in
and what you'll find here is that we've
tried to rearrange some of these
resources
so that you can easily access different
things
in the order that we have
kind of prepared for this program so
you'll notice here that we have
some courses that are introductory and
then some courses that
are project based and then we also some
code
based analyses here so for example
python coding and coding with r getting
started with bioinformatics and things
like that
so what we'll take a look at is this
course on genomics now
in the course of this uh program
we're going to you'll you're going to
see some new materials added here
about different statistical tests
machine learning approaches
and examples of different projects that
we're going to be covering
in this session so
you'll also learn you'll also see how
different courses
or lessons inside courses have this tag
for learn which means that it is using
the platform
with a user-friendly interface and
introduces some theoretical material
coding in r will provide you with some
exercises that you can complete
and see that you've done the assignment
correctly
and then you'll also see a coding with
python
uh so how many of you are here on this
course i'm just going to paste the link
here and i want to uh demonstrate uh
one of these
just how it works i know that some of
you are already familiar
but please let me know once you're in
here
so again i pasted the link in the chat
box
and this is a free course by the way uh
so you'll see that
um the lessons that i will show you
today
are completely free so anyone can do
those
so please put number one when you're in
okay thank you courage and we will go
into
this lesson called working with dna
sequences
all right excellent so
in the context of r it's an
object-oriented language
and we can deal with sequences as
objects
asking questions about the comparison
between them
and trying to identify specific
differences when we know that the
context is that
overall these sequences are comparable
or
very similar to each other so here you
can see that one of the first things
that we'll review
is pairwise alignment and one of the
important
uh kind of parts of this learning is
that you don't only learn about the
problem but you also get to try it now
some of these are as simple as just
pressing
the run button and it will run in the
background
and produce this output so you can see
global pairwise alignments
single subject one of one and then you
can see the pattern
the subject and a score and this is a
similarity score and you saw the little
fireworks come out at me at the screen
and that means that i've done this
correctly
and so you can see here that this
introduces us to some basic ideas about
how to work with art we have to
call a library the library contains
specific
functions we have to provide it with a
data set that is stored as an object so
we have here
two objects dnac 1 and dna 62 and then
when we perform multiple
alignment we also print it at the end
and that allows us to test whether we
have done it correctly but also to see
a score of alignment now
this is the output and now we can try
another uh a different comparison of
sequences right so these sequences were
at a score 102.68 something
and now we can run another one which is
going to be
a little bit different okay so again i
get the fireworks
but you can see that the score of my
analysis
is much lower 55. and so a natural
question would be to say
okay well can i look at the specific
sequence
sequence one and sequence two and try to
understand
why is this difference and so the reason
is that
obviously these are different lengths
okay and so there's different links here
the different links
there and i can start looking for okay
well what are the specific changes maybe
in the beginning
right you can see a t g g a t t
t right so this has much better
similarity overall
even though the links are also different
here so as you go through these
different
types of assignments eventually you will
be
introduced to a project
and so for example here you get a small
assignment these assignments again you
can run them to understand
how they work okay here you see
some basic alignment here you will see
some kind of a visual in in
visual result that you can check
okay and instead of looking at the
console output you'll actually
validate that there are specific changes
right we can forget about
everything else and we can just look at
the specific changes in the sequence
and so forth so going through these
assignments
you will also get introduced to how this
is relevant
to a biological problem and the
biological problem that we are looking
at here
is metabolism of a specific drug
now metabolism of drug is an important
component
in what's called pharmacogenomics right
so when a pharmacist
gives a drug to a patient they want to
know that this drug is going to be
metabolized well and so you can see
how specific mutations and now we need
to think about
what types of mutations are out there
have an
impact on this basic pharmacological
aspect
of assigning treatment to a patient so
these
concepts are built to combine the
specific practical skills like
r with an understanding of genomic data
and how it relates to biological
understanding of dna variation and then
gives you a glimpse of the importance of
such genomic variation in a variety of
applications
so i just wanted to make sure that it's
clear what that
really entails okay so these are going
to be
some examples of our scripting
and working with specific libraries and
methods of analysis of
small data now we will also
look at how the specific variation in
larger data sets and here you can see a
number of whole genome sequences in
fastq files could be analyzed
using a visual report
okay so this is actually also a
practical assignment
it's considered to be basic because
really you're working at consensus
sequences
and the result of a comparison of
multiple
longer sequences that has been prepared
on the t-biometric platform so to talk
about that
in our next session we'll talk about
mapping reads
addressing technical variation and
performing what's called per
nucleotide analysis so when we talk
about per nucleotide analysis what that
means
is that we take individual reads
from the raw fast q files that are often
stored
as sequence read archives and we want to
understand
what are the specific changes as you can
see here not all of them
are going to have a huge impact on the
consensus
and not all of them have an equal
influence
on what we consider to be a snip
a variant or a mutation that causes a
change
in the amino acid sequence so we'll
really think about how
fast q files and the raw reads could be
used
to analyze clusters of changes in
a number of reads combinations
of reads that represent haplotypes
within a given sample
as well as the consensus sequence that
might change
as we try different types of reference
genomes
and as we address the technical
variation
by trimming reads and also eliminating
mapped
regions onto the host genome
that's also an important part of the
type of variation that we will find
we'll also talk a lot about mutation
analysis so often times
the problem statement sounds like this
here's a set of mutations that we know
contributes to drug resistance for
example in the context of malaria
to chloroquine so if we know those
mutations how can we actually look for
those mutations
and characterize the nucleotide sequence
variation that we observe
to what's called variant calling now
variant calling has
several different specific parameters to
it
when we look at calling variants that
are present in all of the reads
when we look at variant calling present
in a portion of the reads
or when we look for specific variants
that we know how to interpret
and forget about the rest and so we'll
talk about
differential mutations how those
variants could be called and
analyzed together with what we know from
a reference or an annotation database
and also how do we interpret the
biological meaning
of some of those mutations in the
context of other mutations
that are present throughout the genome
in our next session we'll talk about
allele frequency and we'll talk about
variation frequency
and the continuous data that allows us
to study
large data sets without looking
at the specifics before we've identified
what is
appropriate and significant for a data
set that we're studying
a good example for this is this example
from the ebola virus
where we took the per nucleotide
analysis
we created mutability scores for each
position
for each sample and position we grouped
our samples into specific
geo-location-based groups and now we're
asking the questions
how the specific mutations in a gene
or the whole genome can characterize
subpopulations of these viruses or
parasites this is an example from
malaria
that will have a significant effect
on the variation right because we're
looking at
the characterization of the population
based on
mutations individual positions
abundances of mutations in particular
regions
or just the conservation of particular
regions
maybe that has an importance for their
specificity to the population
we'll also talk in depth about
differential mutations
that have a that we need to understand
in terms of the statistical significance
of the parameters that we have in a
given data set so for example we already
talked about
coverage we talked about mutation
frequency
and now we're going to combine the two
to perform
some advanced statistical analysis of
mutations that are
either more prevalent in a particular
group of samples or in another one right
so it's kind of like differential gene
expression
but in application to mutations and so
we'll take a look at
some of these examples then we will
apply them to genomic data from ebola
viruses from malaria
and from other pathogens we'll spend
also
some additional time speaking about
the sequence and structure relationship
and so what's important and what we have
not really covered in the previous part
of the program
is with the growing number of data sets
that are available
what is needed is the integration of
these different parameters
to quickly go through genomic variation
relationship at the phylogenetic level
association
different phenotypes and the structural
components that allow us to
ask questions and make interpretation
quickly
and so what we're hoping to achieve
during this session by the way this
session is going to be available for
anyone that would like to join
is to prepare a collection of impactful
examples
using malaria covet 19 polio
and other types of data sets that we
have been working with over the past
several
months so that we can provide an
important
view of data linkage and examples
where we can rapidly explore data and
make
generate hypotheses based on the
available data quickly
and so hopefully we will create a
resource by that time together with you
and your collaboration
with annotated samples with important
phenotype genotype relationships
based on phylogenetic analysis and
mutation analysis that could be explored
by others
that join that session an important part
here
is to be able to look at various
statistical properties
like correlation frequencies
analysis of variance and perplexity
that will allow us to capture important
regions
that are more or less susceptible to the
different types of genomic variation
to be able to ask questions about
phenotype right because
oftentimes our hypothesis is driven by
knowledge and not by exploratory data
analysis
so we will focus on some of the methods
of exploratory analysis
like principal component analysis like
statistics for mapping and normalization
as well as analysis of regions that are
more or less susceptible so that we can
gain a snapshot of big data sets that we
have to deal with
that contain thousands of samples and we
have to make a selection
about specific variation associated with
conditions
in our next session we'll talk about
biological interpretation
of population structures immune
pressures
and rates of transmission as we look at
some of the characteristics
found in visual representation of
genomic data
such as phylogenetic trees relationships
based on clustering
or analysis of multiple sequence
alignment scores
so we'll look at how we can use this
numeric data
to inform our biological interpretation
and understanding of data
and as i mentioned we will also spend
some additional time
on analysis of 3d protein structures
looking at
important proteins responsible for the
process of infection
like the source cove two spike protein
looking at interaction
of different proteins responsible for
different sexual stages of malaria
pathogen looking at different types of
changes that the proteins undergo inside
the cell
in the process of infection and then
we'll
also look at genome-wide association
studies
where we will look at genome-wide
association methods
and what the models of genome-wide
association can tell us about
multiple positions across the genome
associated with a phenotype
as well as thinking about such topics
like drug resistance
and evasion from the immune response
and finally we will have a free webinar
that is going to be available again for
everyone to join
that will be focused on structural
computational biology and we are hoping
that by that time
many of you will give us enough uh
kind of examples with your research
projects that we can
incorporate those into a review session
with some
application of molecular dynamics
docking similarities
and look at the relationship between
genomic data
and protein data that has an interesting
application and context and also has
been placed at the right place
in the project in the research projects
overall
so this is just to give you a glimpse of
what will be covered in the program
i know that we're already running over
time and i'm sorry that it's taking a
little bit longer
but we do have the poll ready and now i
would like to ask that you also help us
understand
a little bit more beeps if you could
launch the poll
if you could help us understand a little
bit more about your
background so which country you are from
about your educational background as
well as
why you are interested in learning
genomics
um so uh you know if you work in this
field or
you know if you're just interested or if
you're just new and you want to learn
more
as well as how you would rate this
session
so again this is an introductory session
that we
prepared so that you will be familiar
with the different resources and the
topics that we will be covering
in the upcoming full program and if you
have not yet participated in
other webinars whether you would be
interested so that we can
uh appropriately send you the details
for the upcoming sessions
some of the sessions that we mentioned
today some of the free webinars that are
coming up
as well as some of the review sessions
of research projects for those
that will complete this program in the
next month or so
so again thank you for giving me this
opportunity to provide you with this
review
of the program and i will pass it back
on to bipsa
to conclude with some details about
registration for those of you that have
not
finished your registration process
thank you elia so uh i have closed down
the poll
right now so for everybody who has
uh not yet registered let me show you
how to register for the program
so this is the registration link again i
will post it
one more time in the chat box for
everybody else
who has not gotten the link
so this is the link again to join the
program and once you're on this page as
elia mentioned
you have an introduction to the program
you can watch this video that we have
prepared
to introduce you again to what this
program would be covering
and if you scroll down you would be able
to see the different
sessions that we have so all of our
sessions
on each of these dates are timed at the
same time
which is 9 am csd
and you will be able to see even the
free webinars which are listed here for
the different sessions so please feel
free to
go through this uh list of
the sessions that we have here and so
how do you register for the program
so if you click on get started you would
be coming up with three different
options to register for the program and
again to clarify for everybody
the beginner option gives you access to
all of the
resources that are that we spoke about
today and that are available to
all participants uh participating in
this
program while the intermediate
access gives you the chance to work
one-on-one with a mentor and
work on your project or any other area
or questions or doubts that you may have
so if you
find that you want to have a one-on-one
session or
interested you can join this while the
advanced license takes you a step
further so if you would want to
go ahead and explore more which gives
you the opportunity
to work on your own research
projects with an additional 30 days so
the advanced license gives you an
additional 30 days to work on your
own project with our group here who is
already
working on the several different
projects that dr harpreet showed earlier
and elia has also spoken about
and also the research fellows who are
part of our program
so please make sure that you go through
these three options and whatever
is suitable for you you can take
that option and apply for the program
all of the basic resources that we
discussed like the learn
platform the slack forum as well as all
of
the other resources like the server to
buy info platform would be available to
everybody
who is joining this program the only
difference
is the additional resources that you can
utilize or the additional access that
you can get and once you choose either
of these options you can click the
select option
and here is the payment details that you
can enter and you would be registered
for the program
and please make sure that if you are
somebody who
would want to request for a scholarship
we also have a scholarship
option so i would just send you
this link again let me post this link in
the chat box
so this is only available for a very few
people and if you want to join this
program immediately the next session as
you saw is
on march 16th
so you still have some time all you need
to do is fill up the form
that you have at the end of this page
please make
make sure that you're mentioning your
references
and we would be setting up a meeting
with you and one of your references to
discuss the opportunity
and based upon that meeting you would be
notified whether your scholarship has
been accepted or not
so if you are a student or anybody else
who would require a scholarship please
feel free to set up
this meeting and fill out the
scholarship form and i would again like
to invite
all of you to go ahead and join our i'm
sorry to go ahead and join our groups
so let me go back to the groups one more
time
and in this groups we try to be as
interactive as we can so please make
sure that you are
also reaching out to us as part
of these groups when you are joining
them so thank you so much
for sharing and also this group in
facebook
and for all participants again i want to
invite you all to join slack so you
would have received the slack invitation
it is important that you accept that in
invitation
and start posting any questions that you
may have here
on the group so this goes for everybody
who is joining the program so once
you're registered for the program we
will send you
an invitation to join this slack group
using the email id that you have shared
so please make sure
that you are there in slack
you are able to use slack in case you
are having any issues please let me know
and if you are someone who has just
joined the platform please save
my email id which is marketing at pine
dot
bio as i will be sending you regular
updates
regarding the sessions as well as the
programs
you would not want to miss those updates
so please make sure
that you have the email id saved up and
you can see this
also we have support at
fine dot bio which is the email id of dr
harpreet kaur and you can reach out to
her regarding any of the technical
questions that you would have
once you start going through the courses
and the resources here so please feel
free to save
both of these email ids for future
references
and thank you all again for joining
today's session this session is also
available
on youtube and we will be emailing every
participant regarding this
session again and i hope to see you all
in the upcoming session next week have a
wonderful weekend everyone
thank you and looking forward to
interacting with you soon as well